donc nous vous entendons Pierre
Moscovici sur le rapport de la cour des
contreative à la situation aux
perspectives des finances publiques que
viennent publier la Cour des comptes ce
rapport permet d'enrichir de réflexion à
la perspective des débats de cet automne
relative au projet de loi de finance et
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale
l'an dernier nous avions déjà entendu
sur ce nous avions déjà entendu pardon
ce sera pas le 12 juillet c'est à dire
le rapport est présenté un peu plus tôt
ce qui permet de vous recevoir dès la
fin du mois de juin en outre des fiches
thématiques de revues des dépenses
seront publiées très prochainement par
la Cour et devrait venir compléter notre
information nous aurons l'occasion de
nous entendre à nouveau à cette occasion
monsieur le Premier Président nous vous
écoutons
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les député voici m'avoir
invité pour présenter un rapport qui est
traditionnel mais qui l'est un peu moins
cette année sur la situation les
perspectives des finances publiques je
souhaite saluer l'ensemble de ces
artisans Gambie président de la première
chambre ses équipes Emmanuel genisini
conseiller maître contre rapporteur
Stéphane Guinée qu'on s'est mettre en
service extraordinaire à porteur général
Olivier vazey référendaire Falzone
Emmanuel gessio a conseil extraordinaire
Nicolas terrebet auditeur
cette année comme les précédentes le
rapport porte des messages importants
sur l'état toujours très dégradé de nos
finances publiques et d'essayer de se
projeter sur une trajectoire de
redressement alors que le contexte
économique a fortement évolué depuis les
dernières un mot là-dessus la croissance
ralentit même si la France semble avoir
échapper à la récession contrairement à
l'Allemagne le dynamisme exceptionnel
des rentrées fiscales qui nous a bien
aidés en 2021 2022
ne se répétera sans doute pas une
troisième consécutive et du côté des
dépenses l'inflation et la hausse et
taux d'intérêts augmentent la charge de
la dette qui mobilise une part
importante de nos ressources et je l'ai
dit je le redirai si nous voulons
préserver notre souveraineté budgétaire
si nous voulons restaurer nos marges de
manœuvre pour financer la transition
écologique si nous voulons pouvoir
investir dans le domaine clé est
indispensable d'assainir nos finances
publiques le rapport que je vous protège
comporte quatre chapitres et c'est
là-dessus que je vais axer mon
intervention qui porte sur l'exercice
2022 l'exercice 2023 la trajectoire plus
réelle 2023 2027 et le quatrième plus
novateur est une contribution
transversale et méthodologique de la
Cour des comptes à l'exercice de revues
des dépenses le rspfp de cette année
c'est comme ça que nous l'appelons est
l'occasion de constater que le défi
demeurent très élevé en 2022 je vais
commencer par là nous avons beaucoup
parlé nous parlons toujours beaucoup du
quoi qu'il en coûte dont nous devons
acter définitivement la fin une sortie
qui était annoncée depuis longtemps mais
l'année 2022 qui devait marquer sa
sortie ne l'a pas permis avec
la crise de l'énergie la guerre en
Ukraine la montée de laflation ça
empêchait le retour à la normale des
dépenses publiques l'inflation atteint
des niveaux que nous n'avions pas connu
depuis les chocs pétroliers les années
70 et 80 le gouvernement a choisi de
protéger les ménages des entreprises
grâce à des dispositifs que le bouclier
tarifaire et des primes à la pompe des
choix qui ont permis de sauvegarder le
pouvoir d'achat des ménages la compléter
des entreprises mais qui ont entretenu
une dynamique de dépenses et donc le
déficit a de ce fait rester élevé à 4,5
points 7 points de PIB si je le qualifie
d'élever c'est parce que paradoxalement
nous finances publiques qu'on bénéficié
en 2022 le facteur conjoncturel
relativement favorable d'abord et c'est
logique les mesures de soutien les
crises sanitaire et les dépenses de
relance on diminue de 50 milliards
d'euros c'était attendu mais c'était
considérable même si on sait qu'il y a
eu un relais prix par les dépenses liées
la crise énergétique d'autre part et
comme en 2021 le dynamisme spontané des
recettes publiques a été exceptionnelles
au point que malgré la poursuite des
baisses d'impôts 50 milliards depuis
2017 le taux de prélèvement obligatoire
a atteint en 2022 sont plus haut niveau
historique à
45,4%, il n'a jamais été aussi élevé en
France pourquoi dans ces conditions le
déficit si haut et bien ce qui s'est
passé c'est que ce déficit reste pour sa
plus grande part de nature structurelle
à hauteur de 4 points de PIB et qui ne
va donc pas se résorber du solfait du
redressement de l'économie nous sommes
très loin des normes d'ailleurs
obsolètes qui avaient été fixé par la
loi de programmation de finance publique
2020 18 2022 conséquences la dette
publique est elle aussi très élevée à
100,8 points de PIB supérieur à son
niveau de 2019 autour de 94,2 points
d'augmentation elle est passée de 2375
milliards d'euros en 2019 à 2003 de 1951
d'euros 2022 si une augmentation de 575
milliards d'euros en trois ans je
reviens maintenant toujours au pas de
charge l'année 2023 qui aurait dû être
la première année d'une trajectoire de
redressement disons si je devais
utiliser une formule et je me base sur
les présidents du gouvernement qu'on
peut craindre que soit une année disons
blanche ou de transition en matière de
redressement des finances publiques bien
sûr nous avons eu un hiver doux pas de
rupture d'approvision sur le gaz les
prix d'énergie ont fortement diminué en
début d'année et 2023 demeurent
toutefois marquée par de nombreuses
incertitudes dans du point de vue
géopolitique que financier
dans ce contexte selon le programme de
stabilité notre croissance atteindrait
seulement 1% de 2023 l'inflation
resterait proche de 5%
prévisions qui pour la croissance est un
peu supérieur à celle des différences
conjonctures saillissant des recettes
publiques elle devrait marquer cette
année prévisions du gouvernement
toujours un être ralentissement en terme
réel le gouvernement prévoit qu'elle
pourrait croître de 4,3% ce serait moins
que la valeur du PIB qui augmenterait de
6,5%. et ce décalage explique que le
taux de prélèvement obligatoire devrait
baisser à 44,3% de PIB face à cela la
dépense publique progresserait moins
vite que l'inflation du fait du repli
ses dépenses de soutien face à crise
sanitaires c'est malgré des mesures de
soutien liées énergique toujours
conséquente au total le déficit
augmenterait à nouveau à 4,9 points de
PIB
il n'est pas exclu qu'il y ait une
surprise un peu favorable disons que
c'est une stabilité
légèrement la rose avec un défi
structuel inchangé à 4 points de PIB une
dette qui serait à 109,6 points de PIB
ce qui est un repli de deux points dont
on se réjouirait davantage qui n'était
exclusivement dû au seul effet de
l'inflation sur le dénominateur si
regarde les efforts fait en termes de
désendettement c'est nul en réalité la
conclusion de ce tableau pour 2023 et
que ce sera une année blanche en termes
de redressement des finances publiques
je reviens maintenant à la trajectoire
2023 2027 tracé par le programme de
stabilité j'en ai déjà parlé devant vous
en tant que président du Haut Conseil
des finances publiques je ne serai pas
long notre message est simple ramener le
défi à moins de 3% et j'ajoute
significativement moins de 3% en 2027
cet objectif atteignable mais au prix
d'un effort substantiel sur la dépense
publique d'autant que le Seigneur
macroécumi qui soutenaitif est plutôt
optimiste et donc à la merci d'une
déception
les crises sanitaires puis énergétiques
ont propulsé notre République à des
niveaux historiques la période qui
s'ouvre à partir de 2023 donc
impérativement être mise à profit pour
retrouver des marges de manoeuvre et
redresser nos finances publiques c'est
un point de départ
aux acides et finances publiques ou nous
étions vous comme moi monsieur le
Président la semaine dernière la
première ministre a annoncée que le
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques sera redéposée ce
bureau des assemblées en septembre ce
qui est une bonne chose et j'ajoute j'ai
déjà dit ça maintes reprises que c'est
absolument impératif non seulement
regarde aux engagements européens mais
aussi pour ancrer pour expliciter pour
étayer notre stratégie du sciences
public et ce projet de programme son
finance unique devra selon moi apporter
des réponses à trois enjeux majeurs le
premier
c'est celui du risque divergence au sein
de la zone euro la trajectoire qui est
proposée dans le pestab et moins
ambitieuse que celle de nos principaux
partenaires européens et sous réserve
bien sûr que ceci remplissent leur
propre engagements on devrait constater
une accentuation de la divergence
pendant ce mandat alors que toute la
gouvernance de la zone euro n'est-ce pas
monsieur le député alroy est fondé sur
l'impératif une convergence gage de
solidité de durée le deuxième enjeu issu
du réalisme de prévisions
macroéconomiques utilisées pour
construire cette trajectoire de retour
sur les 3%, j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
dire comme président du hcfp ici qu'il
nous semblait
que les hypothèses macrochmides qui ont
été prévues par le gouvernement à ce
moment-là sont trop optimistes notamment
en termes de croissance potentielle et
conduisent donc à sous-évaluer l'effort
pour atteindre les objectifs de finance
publique le troisième enjeu c'est celui
de la maîtrise des dépenses
satisfaisant il faut être réaliste parce
que si vous aussi avec les hypothèses
sont trop optimistes alors elles ne se
réalise pas
il ne se réalisent pas je par les
objectifs quatrième point je m'y
attendent un tout petit peu plus parce
que je pense que c'est le plus novateur
de ce rapport pour ça que je me suis
permis de passer très vite sur les trois
premiers la revue des dépenses à
laquelle s'est engagé le gouvernement
que la Cour propose d'accès sur la
qualité et les résultats
une revue des dépenses est à mes yeux
indispensable et elle peut être un
moment très puissant au service des
objectifs de la programmation plus
annuel si elle est menée avec
détermination dans la durée si elle
porte sur un périmètre large et si elle
implique est responsabilise tous les
niveaux d'administration publique
chez nos voisins un tel exercice n'est
rien une nouveauté chez nous il n'a
jamais existé c'est aussi simple que ça
nous avons eu des expériences préalables
il y a eu les audits de modernisation de
l'État en 2005 il y a eu les RGPP en
2007 il y a eu ce qu'on a appelé la MAP
en 2012 le plan action public 2022 en
démarche qui était pour l'essentiel
limitée aux dépenses de fonctionnement
courant de l'état qui nous aboutit qui a
des résultats très modestes et en
réalité totalement budgétaires et la
dynamique de notre dépense publique en
atteste
la nouvelle génération de revue de
dépenses doit en tirer les leçons et
elle doit être conçue dès l'origine
comme exercice plus ambitieux c'est
l'occasion de mettre en place une
gouvernante et finance publique saine et
efficace en associant je suis sur ce mot
toutes les administrations publiques les
taxes opérateurs la sécurité sociale les
collectivités territoriales en portant
les forces sur non pas seulement les
dépenses de fonctionnement courantes
mais toutes les dépenses de
fonctionnement et d'investissement pour
tous les secteurs et toutes les dépenses
doivent être soumises aux exigences
similaires de qualité de soutenabilité
pour ça vous en placez la qualité de la
dépense publique au cœur de notre
contribution a prévu de dépenses et nous
avons identifié des pistes
d'amélioration j'ai une conviction
répétée c'est que la réduction brutale
uniforme des dépenses publiques n'est
pas une solution j'ai dit moins de fois
que l'austérité était la pire des
options et le rabot la pire des
procédures la plus stupide
seule la recherche de qualité et
déficience doit être la clé de la
maîtrise de la dépense pourquoi soulever
cette question la qualité de la dépense
pour mieux la maîtriser parce que je
fais comme beaucoup je crois comme vous
le constat d'un paradoxe français de la
dépense nous sommes un pays qui a choisi
une part importante de socialisation
c'est un choix collectif et qui au fond
ne s'est jamais démenti depuis 50 ans
alors il y a des hauts et des bas il y a
des options politiques différentes en
gros quand même on n'a jamais quand même
mis un coup de sérieux là dessus
ça peut fonctionner à une condition
c'est que la satisfaction légère du
service public soit élevée or on
constate que depuis le début des années
2000 elle ne cesse de baisser alors que
la dépense elle accrue de 28% en volume
par habitant depuis 2000
qu'est-ce que ça signifie ça signifie
que nos concitoyens sont en droit de se
tourner vers les décideurs publics vers
vous mesdames et messieurs les députés
le gouvernement perso aussi qui
participe au site internet je ne mets
pas à l'écart de ça en disant qu'est-ce
que vous faites de notre argent nous
voulons bien dépenser beaucoup mais à
condition que ça marche très bien or
quand on constate que par exemple
l'éducation nationale recule dans les
classements pizza ou que notre politique
du logement je sais qu'elle prête à
débat et prend fortement inadapté
qu'elle ne répond à aucun de ces
objectifs ni la construction ni le
logement social on se dit
il faut dépenser beaucoup peut-être
dépensez mieux c'est ça la logique de la
qualité nous avons réfléchi sur la
qualité de la dépense en partant de
questions simples à trois étages clés
conception déploiement évaluation au
titre de la conception des dispositifs
de dépenses il nécessaire de mieux
étayer leur valeur ajoutée leur utilité
au travers notamment la ciblage plus
pertinent d'Acigné à signer à ses
dépenses et l'outils plus clair mieux
hiérarchisés de veiller à ce que ces
dépenses soient cohérentes non
redondantes par rapport à dispositif
existants tout ça a l'air de bon sens
mais je vous renvoie au rapport pour
constater nombreux exemples à l'appui
que ce n'est pas toujours le cas loin
s'en fout il faut aussi veiller plus
qu'aujourd'hui à la cohérence et
initiative entre les différents niveaux
d'administration on associon plus en
amont et plus étroitement les parties
prenantes par ailleurs la compatibilité
climatique c'est à la cohérence et que
nous engagements enfin la transition
écologique doit être vérifiée dès la
conception de la dépense
ce critère sont déjà pour partie l'objet
de l'étude d'impact obligatoire depuis
2009 mais celle-ci ne se plie pas la
totalité des textes et non pas enrayé la
dynamique de la dépense lui qui ni
d'ailleurs améliorer beaucoup leurs
qualités depuis très longtemps c'est
donc à une véritable montée en gamme des
études d'impact et des évaluations
préalables que nous appelons avec une
idée un peu disruptive que je défends
devant vous la contre-expertise
académique systématique et indépendante
des études d'impact je sais que cette
idée se heurte à des objections
notamment dans une culture budgétaire
très orientée sur le monde public très
concentré sur l'exécutif mais je veux le
glisser au passage cette parenthèse pour
moi une conviction très forte c'est que
cette culture doit évoluer changer
s'ouvrir que dans notre pays nous devons
faire un peu avoir un peu moins peur du
débat et de la contre expertise que
c'est le cas aujourd'hui dans un second
temps au titre du déploiement des
dispositifs de dépenses
les crises récentes ont montré c'était
plutôt heureux que l'administration est
capable de réagir vite de dépenser
rapidement lorsque c'est nécessaire en
s'appuyant sur plusieurs outils de
simplification
issus de la révolution digitale
néanmoins en cours de mise en oeuvre
comment trouver un bon équilibre entre
rapidité contrôle du paiement à bon
droit et lutte contre la fraude les
enjeux sont massifs c'est enjeux de
dizaines de milliards de milliards
d'euros en tout cas et la Cour estime
que la revue de dépenses doit intégrer
ces deux dimensions rapidité et contrôle
lutte contre la fraude il doit conduire
à élever au meilleur standards les
dispositifs de contrôle toujours au
stade du déploiement nous observons
qu'une fois les crédit votés les
systèmes de répartition des moyens entre
services territoire opérateurs par
exemple entre université entre tribunaux
entre collectivités territoriales est un
enjeu majeur ce sont ces systèmes là
avec leurs critères qui détermine en
pratique de combien bien plus que le
vote des enveloppes globales bénéficient
or il y a une très grande inertie dans
ces systèmes il privilégie les dotations
historique sans corrélation avec les
coûts auxquels font face au bénéficiaire
sans te dire compte suffisamment des
situations locales il génère
insatisfaction inégalité territoriale
insuffisante prise en compte de la
démographie etc et là encore il me
semble qu'une rue de dépenses doit être
l'occasion de moderniser ces systèmes en
leur donnant plus transparent et
davantage orienté vers la qualité de
service et le gains déficience par
ailleurs nous observons que le volet
performance de la Golf
est très lacunaire et daté je vais même
être un peu rude le volet performance si
je le crains l'administration qui
conçoit ses propres indicateurs de
performance à l'édition à destination de
ses propres corps de contrôle sous le
regard un peu indifférent sauf le
respect que je dois chacun de ceux-ci et
communautaires politiques et du grand
public la voie que nous proposons c'est
celle d'une ouverture d'un grand coup
d'air sur tout cela il faut franchir une
étape audacieuse et ouvrir largement les
données publiques y compris budgétaire
pour que la société
produit ses propres mesures de
l'efficacité et de l'efficience des
dispositifs publics enfin dernière
dimension l'évaluation elle est
indispensable pour mesurer la
performance et surtout pour susciter une
boucle d'amélioration en continu il
devrait désormais selon systématique
d'inclure dans le dispositif juridique
de nouveaux dispositifs de dépenses une
clause d'évaluation associée à leur
limitation dans le temps leur
prolongation se faisant sous condition
de l'analyse de leurs résultats dans la
continuité l'ouverture que j'évoquais il
y a un instant à propos de la mise à
performance nous proposons que
l'évaluation des dispositifs publics
changent véritables
sortent du microcosme public avec des
programmes pluriannuels respectés des
travaux davantage confiés à des
structures du monde académique des
laboratoires universitaires entre autres
voilà Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
j'ai été vite cette grille d'analyse de
la qualité proposée par la Cour permet
de constater certains progrès accomplis
depuis une quinzaine d'années
heureusement mais il y a aussi de très
nombreuses voix d'amélioration qui
exigent parfois de rompre avec des
pratiques très ancrées la dépense plus
qu'en France si elle porte sur
l'ensemble des dépenses sans exclure
quoi que ce soit a priori si la
responsabilise toutes les
administrations sans exception si elle
s'inscrit dans la durée si elle reste
sous tendue pas de volonté de politique
forte cette revue de dépenses peut être
un levier de l'amélioration de la
qualité de la dépense publique et de sa
soutenabilité
c'est à cette condition que nous
réaliserons enfin une vraie revue
dépenses publiques disons-le les assises
des finances publiques étaient un bon
début elles ont marqué une volonté mais
elles ne peuvent pas être une fin ni une
fin en soi ni une fin tout court
le début d'un processus où on ouvre
beaucoup plus que ça évite le cas le
débat sur les finances publiques où on
procède elle devrait revu on ne se
contente pas d'une analyse budgétaire
mais on va beaucoup plus loin dans
l'analyse des politiques publiques dans
leur réforme car c'est la seule façon de
générer une maîtrise de la dépense qui
ne soit pas mécanisme et donc frustrante
à défaut nous produirons un exercice
utile sur le plan financier mais qui ne
traitera pas les problèmes à la racine
qui ne permettra pas d'améliorer les
politiques publiques qui ne permettra
pas d'améliorer la satisfaction à
l'égard des services publics faire des
économies ça peut être le résultat d'une
revue des dépenses publiques parce qu'il
s'agit bien de dépenser mieux à moindre
coût mais ce n'est pas le préalable
autrement dit ça n'est pas un exercice
budgétaire c'est difficile parfois à
comprendre mais c'est pas du tout la
même chose enfin comme je l'ai rappelé
lors des acides finances publiques il
est temps de passer l'action c'est
pourquoi la cour est plus que jamais à
la disposition du pouvoir législatif du
pouvoir exécutif des citoyens pour
mettre à profit sa connaissance des
politiques publiques et c'est ainsi en
effet vous l'avez monsieur le Président
que nous avons réalisé 9 notes
thématiques dans neuf domaines d'action
prioritaires les dépenses fiscales les
aides aux entreprises ont en temps de
crise la transition écologique
l'éducation les forces de sécurité
intérieure lire les relations
financières avec les collectivités la
formation professionnelle le logement et
les soins de ville pour justement
montrer comment on peut c'est pas du
tout exhaustif évidemment l'ouverture
que nous appelons nos vœux doit
s'appliquer à nous-mêmes je le dis tout
de suite et comment on peut mettre en
oeuvre davantage cette méthodologie je
reviendrai la semaine prochaine vous
présenter ces travaux merci de votre
attention et maintenant je suis à votre
disposition avec ceux qui m'entourent
notamment la prise en compte à vos
questions merci monsieur le président
de cette présentation
et comme de coutume je vais ouvrir la
discussion et les questions
la cour remonte que le niveau atteint
par l'activité économique en 2022
demeure un fer de près 3% au niveau
attendu pour 2022 dans le PLF pour 2020
et que par rapport à son niveau d'avant
crise la France plus 0,9 % fait moins
bien que la zone euro prise dans son
ensemble plus de,3%. je je c'est ce qui
est dans votre rapport comment expliquer
vous ce que je peux considérer comme une
contreperformance vous insistez sur la
dégradation du sol public puisque les
dépenses seraient stables en volume et
manifestent que le principal paramètre
de ces dégradations et celui des
recettes avant même d'aborder les
modifications de la législation la
course souligne que la progression des
cotisations sociales soient 6,7% à je
cite était freiné par l'impact
croisement des allégements généraux
ainsi que l'indique ensuite votre
rapport je cite toujours les mesures
nouvelles ont en training diminution des
prélèvements obligatoires de 53,9
milliards d'euros 2022 par rapport à
2017 et cette baisse nette importante
résultent notamment de la baisse du taux
normal de l'impôt sur les suicides de 33
à 25 % soit moins 11,1 milliard d'euros
de la baisse des impôts de production -
11,3 milliards d'euros en comparaison
avec 2021 ces choix aurait contribué à
détériorer le déficit structurel de
moins 0,3 points de PIB avez-vous pu
estimer la perte structurelle du
haut-mur discrétionnaire annoncée ou
déjà engagé d'ici à 2027 par ailleurs le
gouvernement a revu à la baisse son
estimation du produit de la très modeste
contribution sur les rentes infra
marginales des producteurs d'électricité
qui avait été instauré en loi de finance
pour 2023 ainsi comme il était possible
de s'en douter elle ne rapporterait
finalement que 3,1 milliard d'euros et
nous comme on l'annonçait à l'automne
dernier 9,7 milliards d'euros ne
craignez-vous pas que d'autres recettes
est connu de cette manière une prévision
artificiellement gonflée
votre rapport rappelle l'impératif de
ramener le déficit à moins de 3% du PIB
en 2027 tout en indiquant que cet
objectif était atteignable au prix je
cite d'un effort substantiel sur la
dépense publique à savoir une évolution
de la dépense publique en volume limitée
à 0,4 % par an d'autant plus si on tient
compte de la loi de programmation
militaire ce que la France n'a jamais
connu de plus plusieurs décennies dans
le même temps la Cour souligne que
l'activité économique faiblit à nouveau
en 2023 que l'inflation ne recule que
faiblement et que les incertitudes sur
la croissance demeure encore forts
n’êtes-vous pas inquiet de les faire
récessif possible que pour induire une
contraction durable des dépenses
publiques ce qui aura alors un effet
négatif sur le taux d'endettement
enfin plutôt que du côté des dépenses
publiques ça ce que je viens de dire
l'enduit ne choisit pas du coup plutôt
rechercher du côté des dépenses fiscales
pour réduire l'endettement public je
pense notamment aux crédit pour
recherche aux allègement de cotisation
et contributions sociales et plus
généralement aux aides entreprises non
conditionnées je note d'ailleurs que
dans votre rapport la dépense publique
est considérée en incluant les crédits
d'impôts enregistrés en dépense en
comptabilité nationale enfin je voudrais
vous poser une question liée à
l'addition que nous avons eu hier d'un
rapport qui a été commandé par le
gouvernement sur
en gros l'impact sur les activités
économiques et sur les questions de
finance de des questions
environnementales du rapport bisaniferi
et Selma mafouze ici même
monsieur Pisani ferry nous a expliqué
que il fallait plus 66 milliards d'euros
par an d'ici 2030 d'investissement
supplémentaires
sur pour espérer une bifurcation
écologique bien il a donné des recettes
en gros l'idée c'est que le quoi qu'il
en coûte au moins de manière écologique
n'est pas derrière nous mais et
devons-nous vous le savez c'est une idée
que je défends il a donné différentes
recettes qui est certes d'un côté un
redéplace redéploiement des dépenses
brunes une meilleure ingénierie
financière une hausse des dépenses
d'investissement et deux autres recettes
qui peuvent qui peuvent peut-être vous
paraître mais que sur lesquels je
voulais vous faire réagir en lien
justement avec l'idée que
l'inaction coûte plus cher que l'action
bon
c'est la hausse de l'endettement public
de 5 à 6 points de PIB d'ici 2030 x 2
d'ici 2040 en estimant que c'est un
endettement lié à un question
d'investissement sur la transition
écologique et vous le savez c'est la
hausse temporaire des prélèvements
obligatoires qu'il a chiffré à 5% dans
une fenêtre de 30 ans donc sur les hyper
riches pour aller vite et qui
rapporterait 150 milliards raison 5
milliards d'euros par an là on est donc
dans une dans une perspective qui est un
peu différente de celle que nous a
présentées le ministre Bruno Le Maire
qui Bruno Le Maire vera nous en parler
d'ailleurs ici le 20 septembre par
rapport aux assises des finances
publiques qui qui aborde finalement la
zone grise pour l'instant les laisser de
côté par le gouvernement c'est-à-dire
comment on chiffre et comment on finance
les investissements que tout le monde
estime nécessaire sur la transition
écologique donc je voulais de ce point
de vue là vous fait réagir par rapport à
l'énoncé de vos questions et on passe
aux orateurs de groupe
on va commencer par Madame Patricia
Lemoine pour renaissance pour deux
minutes
allez-y allez-y
je reprends comme vous l'avez rappelé
les crises successives en contrat l'État
à déployer plusieurs dispositifs de
soutien coûteux pour nos finances qui
ont néanmoins étaient particulièrement
efficace pour protéger le pouvoir
d'achat des Français soutenir notre
économie cette politique qui s'appuie
également sur une stratégie de baisse
d'impôts massif de l'ordre de 50
milliards d'euros depuis 2018 s'est
traduite par de nombreuses créations
d'entreprises et d'emplois entraînant
mécaniquement un dynamisme spontané
exceptionnel de recettes publiques
les dépenses publiques de l'État quant à
elle atteignent un niveau historiquement
élevé en 2022 dépassant le seuil des
1500 milliards d'euros phénomène qui se
poursuivra en 2023 même si elle
progresseront moins vite que l'inflation
pour atteindre 56% du pide face à ce
constat le gouvernement à d'ores et déjà
annoncé à l'occasion des Assises des
finances publiques des économies de
l'ordre de 10 milliards d'euros qui
constituent une première étape il a par
ailleurs développé deux réformes
essentielles pour le redressement de nos
finances publiques et de l'activité avec
la réforme des retraites et bien sûr
celle de l'assurance chômage
je voudrais m'attarder sur un point de
votre rapport celui du rôle de financeur
et d'assureur en dernier ressort que
joue l'État au bénéfice des autres
administrations publiques qui ont pour
conséquence de concentrer sur lui le
déficit et la dette publique vous
précisez ainsi qu'il est désormais
nécessaire que tous les acteurs publics
s'engagent dans ces exercices de revues
de dépenses et de gestion de leur dette
cela exige une évaluation de
l'efficacité de la qualité des dépenses
publiques vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Premier Président hors près de 80% des
communes ont moins de 2000 habitants et
ne disposent pas des moyens de la faire
pensez-vous qu'il devient désormais
incontournable d'harmoniser les
différents agrégats états collectivités
territoriales afin de modifier les
règles d'évolution et d'évaluation des
dépenses publiques êtes-vous favorable
dans ces conditions à un pacte financier
entre l'État et les collectivités
territoriales si oui quel pourrait en
être les contours je vous remercie
merci Monsieur Aymeric c'est le mont
pour l'Assemblée nationale oui mais le
président monsieur le Premier Président
je tout d'abord je vous remercie pour ce
rapport annuel qui montre
malheureusement et une fois de plus la
situation dégradée de nos finances
publiques près de 3000 milliards d'euros
de dettes à toute prélèvement
obligatoire en 2022 de 45,4 % du PIB et
des perspectives a priori peut
réjouissantes pour 2023 sur des
perspectives j'ai plusieurs questions à
vous poser ma première question
concernera le mécanisme de correction
qui pourrait s'appliquer pour la France
au titre du pacte de stabilité avec la
sortie des circonstances exceptionnelles
en 2023 est-ce qu'il vous paraît
envisageable que la France finisse
sanctionner par l'Union européenne pour
son budget dégradé ma deuxième question
concerne la revue des dépenses votre
rapport donne une méth une méthodologie
pour évaluer les dépenses mais c'est une
démarche qui n'est pas tout à fait
nouvelle déjà la RGPP puis la map ont
tenté d'opérer une revue des dépenses de
l'État avec des limite connu et très
problématique la RGP à l'époque a
conduit à des fermetures de services de
terrain et à des suppressions de poste
de fonctionnaires de terrain sans
toutefois simplifier le millefeuille
administratif français ma deuxième
question est donc la suivante est-ce que
la Cour des comptes pour être force de
proposition pour la simplification du
mille-feuille administratif et proposer
au cas par cas des suppressions de
doublons ma troisième question va
concerner un sujet que notre groupe
aborde régulièrement depuis l'été
dernier à savoir les eaux ATI à
l'occasion des printemps d'évaluation
mon collectivité de mon vieux a publié
un rapport sur le coût des eaux ATI pour
nos finances publiques la charge
d'indexation du capital des eaux ATI a
coûté 15,5 milliards d'euros en 2022 le
rapport propose la fin des eaux ATI que
pensez-vous de cette idée de mettre fin
à ses eaux ATI en période inflationniste
je vous remercie
merci David Guiraud pour la France
insoumise
merci monsieur le président
c'est toujours étrange parce que bon on
a nos débats sur la dette sur son
utilité mais il est à peine quelques
mois vous arriviez en nous disant que
jamais quasiment de son histoire la
France n'avait engrangé autant de
recettes fiscales notamment dû à la
hausse de la TVA et pourtant on a quand
même l'impression d'un surplace total en
termes de dépenses publiques
notamment dans les secteurs stratégiques
que sont la santé l'éducation et la
question qui se pose est où va tout cet
argent que la France récoltait ce que
vous me confirmez que notamment sur ce
qu'il se passe vis-à-vis du budget de
l'État on a 60 milliards d'euros
d'exonération de cotisations sociales
c'est donc des recettes en moins mais
non seulement ces recettes sont en moi
mais en plus elles sont compensées par
des recettes potentielles celles de la
TVA qui aurait pu aller justement sur
des politiques publiques ce qui fait que
ça a fait ça renforce le déficit sur la
question économique est-ce que vous nous
confirmez parce que c'est quelque chose
qui nous intéresse le rapport du FMI qui
indique l'augmentation générale des prix
a été en majeur en grande partie causée
par une augmentation des bénéfices des
entreprises plutôt que du coût réel des
matières premières enfin j'ai vu ce que
vous disiez sur la fraude je ne sais pas
si vous parlez de la fraude fiscale ou
de la fraude sociale s'agissant de la
fraude sociale est-ce que vous prévoyez
des mécanismes de contrôle des
dispositifs comme l'accompagnement du
RSA avec 10- heures de 15-20h de travail
accompagné par le RSA sachant que dans
une ville comme Roubaix moi j'ai 10 000
locataires du RSA et en vérité les
agents n'ont absolument pas les moyens
de mettre en place une telle politique
et que donc on va se conduire vers un
système soit de radiation généralisé
soit de triche ou de manœuvres
généralisée pour pallier au manque
d'effectif et que parfois les
dispositifs de contrôle coûte plus
d'argent qu'il n'en rapportent
merci fabiendy Philippot pour les
républiques merci Président je tiens à
remercier le premier président de la
Cour des comptes pour les éléments
factuels qui nous a transmis et qui
confirme de choses plutôt inquiétantes
le premier le statut de mauvaise élève
de la zone euro de notre pays et on voit
audition après audition malheureusement
l'écart entre la générosité de notre
modèle social d'un côté et nos capacités
à produire de la recherche pour le
financer de l'autre grandir et puis
deuxièmement le caractère irréaliste de
la trajectoire du gouvernement qui
repose finalement plus sur de la méthode
Coué que sur une vision lucide avec une
croissance maintenant on en avait
certitude surévalué une inflation sous
évaluée et il ne faut pas l'oublier
monsieur le Président un niveau de
chômage sans doute aussi un peu
sous-évalué et un niveau d'inactivité
qui augmente alors il est temps de tirer
la sonnette d'alarme pour éviter une
dynamique irréversible de paupérisation
du pays pour les décennies à venir alors
j'ai trois questions par rapport à ça
comment on compte atteindre les
objectifs que vous dites atteignable et
journaliste pour revenir sous les 3% de
déficit en 2027 avec des lois de
programmation dans différents domaines
intérieurs justice défense qui renvoie
le gros des augmentations budgétaires
après 2027 ou en est l'effet boule de
neige de la dette et de sa charge à
quelle vitesse augmentent-elles et quand
sera-t-elle le premier poste budgétaire
de l'État devant l'éducation nationale
et enfin sur les retraites on voit
qu'avec les nouvelles prévisions du
corps la sous-évaluation du taux de
chômage dans les prévisions du
gouvernement et bien même le décalage à
64 ans ne suffit plus ça veut dire que
notre modèle par répartition il est
clairement condamné donc est-ce qu'il
faut commencer à envisager autre chose
que ce système para répartition pour
assurer des pensions décentes à ceux qui
auront travaillé toute leur vie sans
grever complètement les budgets de
l'État ou sans comme la souhaiter le
collègue juste avant et bien augmenter
encore la charge fiscale des entreprises
et des ménages
merci Luc gesmar pour le groupe modem
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Vice-Président je vous rejoins
tout d'abord sur un constat posé dans le
rapport que vous ne présentez ce jour
dans le contexte de nécessaire maîtrise
de la dépense publique
nous devons d'adopter une loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pour la période 2023 2027 j'espère
que les débats que nous aurons fin
septembre mes chers collègues nous
permettront cette fois-ci d'aboutir en
responsabilité à l'adoption d'un texte
j'aborderai deux thèmes de questions le
financement de la transition écologique
et la revue des dépenses publiques alors
tout d'abord dans votre rapport vous
affirmez que l'objectif inédit de
maîtrise de la dépense publique sera
d'autant plus difficile à respecter car
il faudra notamment garantir le
financement
d'investissement écologique Jean Pisani
ferry et Selma
que nous auditionnions hier chiffres ses
besoins de financement
jusqu'à 34 milliards d'investissements
publics supplémentaires par an horizon
2030 pour s'adapter aux objectifs
environnementaux sachant que votre
programme de travail est placé en 2023
sous le signe de l'adaptation à la
transition environnementale quelle est
la vie de la cour des de la cour sur
cette hypothèse de 34 milliards par an
horizon 2030 puis comment concilier une
maîtrise de la dépense publique que vous
appelez de vos vœux et le financement de
la transition écologique par ailleurs
dans votre rapport vous concentrez
notamment sur la revue des dépenses nous
partageons votre constat le
développement d'une revue de des
dépenses publiques la plus large
possible et nécessaire pour aboutir à
des résultats à satisfaisants vous
affirmez notamment de nombreux pays
organisent des revues de dépenses et
leur accord d'une place centrale dans la
gouvernance de leur finance publique
pouvez-vous nous préciser qu'elles sont
les pays ces pays auxquels vous faites
référence et nous dire nous en dire plus
sur les les bonnes pratiques que vous
aurez pu
identifier dans ces pays et qui
pourraient être mis en place dans notre
beau pays
merci
Philippe Brun pour les socialistes
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Président merci pour cette
présentation sur rapport sur perspective
des finances publiques intéressants et
le tableau que vous faites un sur
l'évolution des dépenses publiques
depuis 2000 et finalement on se rend
compte que toutes les dépenses publiques
n'augmentent pas et qu'un certain nombre
de postes budgétaires eux ont diminué
par exemple les dépenses de service
généraux ont réduit à hauteur de deux
points de pips qui est élevé et qui a
été permis par la digitalisation mais
aussi je le crois par une certaine
embolie dans les services publics
administratifs on le voit avec le
problème qu'on nous avons en ce moment
sur les cartes d'identité et les
passeports les dépenses d'enseignement
aussi on réduit depuis 2000 à hauteur de
0,4% du PIB même chose également pour
les dépenses d'investissement qui ont
réduit de la même hauteur à 0,4% depuis
et donc l'augmentation de la dépense
publique elle s'explique par
l'augmentation des dépenses de
protection sociale pour moitié la
maladie pour l'autre moitié
la retraite et donc liée au
vieillissement de la population
l'augmentation la plus étonnante en
vérité et celle des dépenses économiques
à hauteur de 2,4 points pour cent du PIB
et vous regardez d'ailleurs les 2100
dispositifs de dépenses économiques qui
sont aujourd'hui prévues liés vous
parlez même d'un éparpillement d'un
foisonnement de ces aides aux
entreprises mal pilotées et mal dirigé
vous donnez par exemple le cas du fond
de relance état région qui devait
décaisser dès 2022 250 millions d'euros
et qui n'a été réalisé qu'à hauteur de
23%. alors ma question est la suivante
comment mieux coordonner aujourd'hui la
distribution de ses aides économiques
nous recherchons toutes et tous ici la
voix des rétablissements de nos finances
publiques et baisse en tout cas dépense
publique
inutiles c'est dépenses économiques qui
font de la France le champion européen
des aides aux entreprises mériteraient
d'être davantage piloté comment le faire
dans le contexte de la décentralisation
et de la compétence économique
aujourd'hui qui est donnée aux régions
merci Monsieur Karim benchek pour le
groupe écologie
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Président Monsieur le Président
merci pour cette présentation qu'elle
mérite d'être claire notamment sur les
dernières réformes injustes et brutal
sans ces soulager nos finances publiques
vous affirmez que pour ramener le défi
de budgétaire cela a été rappelé à 3 %
d'ici 2027 le gouvernement doit à la
fois préserver les recettes mais que
cela doit passer par un effort
substantiel sur les dépenses publiques
le rapport de la Cour des comptes
indique également noir sur blanc que les
réformes structurées d'engagées comme la
réforme des retraites celle de
l'assurance chômage ou programmée comme
celle du RSA ou de Pôle Emploi nori je
cite qu'un impact marginal sur
l'exercice des mois donc finalement que
le gouvernement Martel que sent cette
réforme des retraites le système
s'écoule ré nous comprenons donc que
cette réforme injuste ne changera rien à
l'état de nos finances publiques et
changera par contre beaucoup trop la vie
de nos compatriotes les plus vulnérables
nous souhaitons par ailleurs vous
soumettre quelques interrogations dans
ce contexte budgétaire tendu et alors
que l'objectif de préserver les recettes
dans quelle mesure considérez-vous
raisonnable et nouvelle baisse d'impôts
en direction des entreprises et
notamment la suppression totale de la
c.e laquelle inquiète toutes nos temps
nos collectivités qu'elle regard
portez-vous sur la perte de ressources
quant au même moment le gouvernement
refuse en plus à faire contribuer les
profiteurs de ce contexte notamment en
taxant les sur profits le rapport
indique également qu'il faudra garantir
le financement d'investissement
écologique dans un contexte de baisse
substantielle de la dépense publique
c'est ici notre analyse c'est ici que
notre analyse rejoint la vôtre la
transition écologique est solidaire
c'est souhaitable et nécessaire mais
pensez-vous pas que la règle des 3%
risque plutôt de contraintes fortement
les capacités d'investissement public
comment dès lors assurer de manière
certaine le financement tellement urgent
de l'adaptation et de la prévention
enfin et je finis par ce point vous
proposer une importante contribution sur
la revue des dépenses publiques à
laquelle vous souhaitez donner un sens
écologique et ou le saluons une remarque
cependant qui rejoint un petit peu celle
de mon collègue Philippe Brun vous
dénoncez les précédentes revues
rappelant que leur impact a été au final
marginal sur les finances publiques
alors que en même temps l'insatisfaction
à l'égard des services publics a
augmenté je comprends donc ces revues
outre le fait qu'elles aient participé
au démantèlement de nos services publics
dont le service public diplomatique est
consulat que vous connaissez bien non
pas eu d'impact majeur sur la dépense
publique c'est là un point qui devrait
effectivement mériter aussi toute notre
attention merci merci j'ai deux inscrits
supplémentaires j'ai monsieur alroyd et
Monsieur mournet s'il y en a pas
d'autres je propose de les prendre
maintenant une minute chacun donc on
commence par Monsieur alroy dans l'ordre
des inscriptions
merci beaucoup monsieur le
au moment où il y a un besoin de
financement de la transition écologique
qui est extrêmement important et qui
conduit donc à la seule conclusion
logique au regard des dépenses publiques
dans le PIB c'est à dire qu'il faut une
réaffectation profonde de nos dépenses
publiques en leur sein moi j'ai une
question à vous poser monsieur le
Premier Président qui est une question
que je pose à l'ancien ministre à
l'ancien parlementaire etc c'est que
vous donnez une certaine série de
propositions d'ouverture à la donnée
transparence etc
c'est au fond l'intention de la Golf si
je me souviens de conversation que j'ai
eu avec les inspirateurs de la loi
c'était la même inspiration qu'ils
avaient plus de contrôle plus de
transparence plus de données plus de
transparence avec les Parlement et force
est de constater qu'après avec un
certain recul
de façon discutable et la question que
j'ai vraiment pour vous c'est comment se
fait-il que cette institution notre
assemblée notre commission des finances
n'arrivent pas depuis près de 20 ans à
se saisir le sujet avec le
l'efficacité qu'elle devrait avoir parce
que au fond la ligne de contrôle la
dernière ligne de contrôle budgétaire
c'est cette commission des finances et
c'est cette assemblée et en l'occurrence
toutes les questions que vous pointez
doivent nous ramener à me protège notre
propre responsabilité bien sûr qu'il y a
le gouvernement qui peut le faire bien
sûr que les inspections des mystères qui
peut le faire mais éventuellement c'est
ici que ce contrôle doit se faire et la
réalité c'est que malgré les intentions
de nos prédécesseurs cette réaffectation
cette question de l'utilité des dépenses
publiques ne se contrôle pas c'est
efficacement malgré tous les efforts d'à
peu près tous les groupes par exemple
dans le printemps de l'évaluation donc
ma question c'est vraiment aux
responsables politiques qui a occuper
toutes ces fonctions de savoir un peu
quel est votre analyse de la faiblesse
de notre système instinctionnel vous
aurez atteint deux minutes monsieur
Bournet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Président merci pour votre
présentation
je souscris à la méthode et au fond
d'ouvrir les fenêtres et de d'une
méthode champ large Vander comme vous
avez dit sur nos revues des dépenses
peut-être je sais pas une idée peut-être
une convention citoyenne mais
effectivement je rejoins ce que dit mon
collègue c'est que on bute quand même
année après année sur où est-ce qu'on
tranche donc est-ce que la limite de
l'exercice de l'efficience l'efficacité
ce qu'on n'est pas au bout et est-ce
qu'on doit pas un moment donné se poser
des questions sur des grands choix et
dans la présentation peut-être aussi de
détourer ce qui relève de la sécurité
sociale qu'un choix de de socialiser et
de ce qui relève des autres politiques
budgétaires et fiscales et ce qui de
question là-dessus est-ce que en
comparaison internationale et en
comparaison européenne où est-ce que
sont les grands écarts avec nos
partenaires dans les dans les dans les
écarts de dépenses publiques
et deuxième élément est-ce que la Cour
des comptes c'est penché ou saisi de la
question de la comptabilité écologique
qui est menée par à la fois l'ordre des
experts-comptables et des chercheurs
d'agro ParisTech Alexandre Rambot et
Monsieur gebault de mémoire et qui est
assez intéressantes et en écho avec ce
que Monsieur Pisani ferry notre
président qui l'évoquait tout à l'heure
nous indiquer aujourd'hui comme une
nécessité absolue je vous remercie merci
Monsieur Monet juge peut permettre je
faisais une réflexion en lien avec ce
que vous disiez monsieur l'oreille au
président de la con je la fais tour
c'est qu'il y a des crochage certes mais
il y a peut-être aussi un rapport avec
le fait que ce décroche il y a des
crochage et d'un autre côté on n'est pas
en récession contrairement aux Allemands
et ça c'est la deuxième fois où ça se
passe c'était passé déjà par rapport à
la crise des suprame ou jaillir le
matelas des dépenses publiques
françaises avaient soutenu une activité
économique française par rapport à nos
voisins peut-être que l'un explique
aussi l'autre en tout cas je le mets sur
la table et maintenant je donne la
parole au président de la Cour des
comptes pour nous répondre
merci je commencerai par vos questions
naturellement monsieur le Président
d'abord sur cette contreperformance en
effet
c'est une question spécialisation de
l'économie pour chaque pays vous notez
que la France fait presque aussi bien
que l'Italie à boursan mieux que
l'Allemagne 06 ou l'Espagne - 3 moins
bien que les Pays-Bas la Belgique ou
encore l'Autriche et ça s'explique
notamment par des pertes de parts de
marchés exportation plus importantes en
particulier pas souvent dans
l'automobile et l'aéronautique passons
touché par la crise sanitaire en France
c'est la demande intérieure qui a
soutenue le PIB de 2019 à 2022 à hauteur
de 3,3 points au total sur 4 ans et ça
en effet c'est l'impact du quoi qu'il en
coûte mais
en termes de dépenses publiques les
niveaux ont été à peu près équivalents
dans l'ensemble des pays de l'Union
européenne niveau initiaux en termes
d'éviter mon situation finance publique
n'étant pas tout à fait les mêmes tandis
que la demande extérieure elle faisait
baisser à hauteur de 2 points sur le
même laps de temps les pays qui ont fait
mieux que la France contre ceux qui sont
exportateurs nets et donc par rapport à
la dernière réflexion que vous faites
elle mériterait d'être un profil
assurément un effet dépenses publiques
amortisseurs sociales états assureur
mais il y a aussi quand même à la fois
pour le bien et pour le moins bien nos
questions spécialisation ce qui est en
cause dans la croissance allemande
d'aujourd'hui me semble-t-il c'est
essentiellement son modèle productif qui
a fait sa force qui a fait sa gloire et
qui est aujourd'hui davantage impacté
que le nôtre et donc il y a la question
de la demande mais aussi comme la
question de l'offre qui doit être
étudiée je pense très près parce que
pour redistribuer et pour dépenser il
faut aussi produire pour ce qui est la
dégradation du service public je vais
répondre l'effet de mesures
discrétionnaires sur le défi structurel
et je voudrais rebondir sur ce que vous
avez dit à savoir que le seul public ne
sait pas dégradé il s'est même amélioré
en passant de moins 6,5 à moins 4,7%
mais ce niveau est encore trop élevé
c'est plus marqué dans la mesure où les
recettes ont été exceptionnellement
dynamique en 2022 le déficit c'est
forcément le résultat d'une équation
c'est les dépenses et les recettes mais
en l'espèce c'est la dynamique de la
dépense qui faisait sur le déficit et
pas une anémie des recettes les mesures
de baisse et prélammatoire ont amputé
les recettes autour de 9,4 milliards en
2022 de 5,2 milliards sur le vendeur
2023 ce qui contribuerait mais
détériorer le seul structurel autour de
0,5 points de pied en 2023 par rapport à
plus difficile d'évaluer l'impact des
mesures discrétions 2027 parce que
justement nous n'avons pas de
documentation suffisante ça
pardonnez-moi mais il faudra que le
moment venu quand l'examen le temps de
l'examen doit être programmation soit
venu qui est quand même une
documentation précise du chemin c'est
pour ça que je parle à la fois
d'objectif ambitieux mais aussi de
l'hypothèse crédible parmi les
hypothèses il y a aussi le chemin qu'on
suit en matière de dépenses mais
là-dessus j'ai passé quelques messages
que je redis ici
d'éventuelles hausse d'impôts ne pour
être que ponctuelle et ciblé ce qui veut
dire qu'il faut pas en attente je pense
à l'habitude de rendement elles peuvent
se justifier pour des raisons politiques
ou sociales elles peuvent financières
dispositives par exemple pensons la
transition énergétique je suis pas du
tout contre l'utilisation de la peau
comme instrument de location de
redistribution il existe mais malgré
tout en termes de niveau de prélèvement
obligatoire je pense que le consentement
l'impôt n'est pas loin du maximum je
pense depuis longtemps en vérité je
l'avais déjà dit il y a longtemps
dans d'autres fonctions j'ai pas
beaucoup changé d'avis en vérité et donc
je pense qu'il faut garder cela puis de
nouvelles baisses d'impôts doivent être
impérativement compensées par les
économies en dépenses je crois vraiment
que nous n'ont pas les moyens
aujourd'hui de baisse un peu sèche je
dis de manière très carré depuis
maintenant une bonne année
soyons prudents là-dessus si une baisse
d'impôts non compensé en perte de
croissance faible avec des dépenses
élevées c'est bénéficie non plus tout
simplement pour ce qui est des recettes
les recettes attendues
de la contribution sur les rentes à
froides marginales dans l'intelligence
sur ce point mais aussi sur les CSPE les
charges du service public de l'énergie
qui
subventionnent les fournisseurs
d'électricité renouvelables sont très
sensibles à l'évolution des prix
électricité sur les marchés
ces derniers ils ont divisés par trois
depuis le pic de l'été 2022 les recettes
attendues ont elles-mêmes été revues à
la baisse en cohérence avec ses
évolutions il ne ressort pas notre
analyse que la prévision de recettes du
gouvernance soit affectée d'un
bioptimiste là-dessus c'est plutôt même
le contraire qui s'est produit en
2021-2022 puisque les prévisions de
recettes ou arrêt étaient trop prudente
même si celle de fin d'année et
l'exécution c'est par deux fois
nettement supérieur c'est du reste qui a
incité la cour inscrit à son programme
de travail pour la fin d'année une
enquête sur les modalités de prévision
de recettes de l'État quand je parle de
prudence je le fais comme preuve de la
cause des comptes je le fais comme
prison du HFP c'est pas un reproche
moral c'est pas c'est juste que nous
avons anticipé assez régulièrement en
fait le hcfp depuis trois ans depuis que
je suis là que à chaque fois nous
allions dépasser l'outils en termes de
recettes c'est effectivement produit sur
le déficit et la dépense
je pense qu'en effet s'il suffisait de
maintenir d'augmenter le niveau dépenses
publiques pour soutenir la croissance
nous aurions pas seulement une fois
monsieur le Président mais
systématiquement une croissance
supérieure assez des autres pays
européens
à mon sens je le dis tout de suite il
s'agit pas de baisser le niveau de la
dépense la Cour n'est pas une
institution qui propose une austérité
brutale bête méchante il s'agit de
l'affaire progresser moins vite qu'à la
coutumée en outre nous proposons une
méthode nouvelle qui est celle de revue
de dépenses qui débouche sur des
économies intelligentes plutôt que arabo
aveugle ce qui devrait éviter de peser
sur le potentiel de croissance enfin je
crois que la réduction de déficit est
impérative pour garantir la
soutenabilité d'être publique et la
charge de la dette s'est établie en
effet à 53 milliards d'euros en 2022
alors même que l'effet de la dose des
taux ne sait pas encore matérialisé une
question m'a été posée sur à quel moment
ça devenait le premier végétal
heureusement dans assez longtemps
puisque le problème de littérature
compte tous c'est l'éducation nationale
bon et on devrait être au dessus de 70
milliards d'euros en 2027 ça veut dire
un triplement par rapport à 2021 compte
une des faits divers l'inflation là aux
étaux
je ne sais pas comment en réalité on
finance une politique de croissance dans
ces conditions c'est ça la vraie la
vraie question enfin vous me demandiez
monsieur le Président s'il fallait pas
rechercher du côté des dépenses fiscales
je vous réponds à la fois oui et non oui
parce que j'ai dépenses fiscales sont
des dépenses non parce que ça ne suffit
pas mais nous allons présenter une note
la semaine prochaine sur ce point et
c'est un sujet évidemment qui reste à
investiguer plusieurs d'entre vous a
commencé par vous monsieur le Président
moins interrogé sur le rapport plus
anify
qui a évidemment un mérite considérable
qui est de jeter un regard panoramique
sur cette grande question et aussi de
donner des évaluations qui je l'ai noté
sont assez peu discutés de lors d'une
soixantaine 60 70 milliards d'euros de
dépenses publiques annuel à partager
entre le public et le privé
là dessus
je me suis exprimé publiquement je vois
un petit peu en sortant de ma condition
de prison à côté pas celle de président
du Conseil des prêts immobiliers
qui a fait des travaux là-dessus mon
sentiment c'est qu'il faut avoir
là-dessus un grand débat sont à bout je
le dis je sais que c'est position n'est
pas exactement celle qui a été prise par
le ministre des Finances je n'ai pas
réagi en disant fermer le banc y compris
sur les impôts non pas parce que j'y
suis favorable je n'ai pas expertisé
cette question mais parce que je crois
que il faut être conscient que cette
dépense là est une dépense nécessaire
elle est nécessaire nous ne pouvons pas
faire l'économie d'un effort massif
d'investissement sur le transition
écologique la question c'est comment
nous le finançons la réponse de la Cour
c'est plutôt que si il faut augmenter
une partie de la dette pour ça alors il
faut réduire la dette de manière plus
conséquente ailleurs c'est quand même
dans un train de désendettement parce
que ce point de vue là il se répond à
une question qui m'a été posée aussi sur
les 3%
monsieur le député c'est pas en
dérogeant en 3% qu'on m'a donné un
potentiel de croissance si on ne les
respectant pas qu'on va atteindre notre
potentiel de croissance parce que je
suis pas fétichiste chez chiffres 3%
c'est en gros le niveau où la dette
s'inverse si on continue d'augmenter la
dette
et bien potentiel pour investir sera
très réduit le jour nous aurons 75
milliards d'euros d'être public service
de la dette annuelle je vous assure que
les pouvoirs publics souffriront vous
massifiez monsieur alroy de porter
témoignages je le déteste le faire en
même temps c'est toujours tentant sur ce
que j'ai vécu quand j'étais misé finance
en 2013 2014
5% difficiles 0% de croissance les
impératifs européens qui
nous aiguillonnaient pour rester poli
vous ne pouvez rien faire en terme de
dépenses rien et donc si vous n'avez pas
respecté vos objectifs des enlèvements
vous ne financerez pas la transition
écologique donc la vraie question pour
moi c'est comment on fait pour financer
ça je pense que là ça demande une vraie
mise à plat un peu de temps du travail
fondamental ça peut pas se régler en
deux coups de cuillère à pot en disant
oui ou non en disant tout de suite on a
trouvé ça n'est pas vrai et donc moi je
suis pour ce débat démocratique je peux
pas préconiser l'ouverture sur les rues
de dépenses et pas être ouvert une
réflexion sur les recettes ce qui ne
signifie pas que j'adhère forcément à
cette proposition mais je trouve que
l'évacuer des renversements comme la
prouvé sont discutés c'est pas tout à
fait en méthode ma conception des choses
pour ce qui est du financement des
collectivités locales madame le député
quelques autres vont mais interroger
là-dessus
il y aura la semaine prochaine une note
qui porte sur les collectivités locales
mais la question vous posez sur les
agrégats avec une question qui est posée
qui est légitimement posée y compris
dans le cadre de leur vie de dépenses
publiques
posées mais nous n'avons pas à ce stade
la réponse de manière très très claire
pour ce qui est des
plusieurs fois les revues de dépenses en
parlant de la rgppe ou de la map etc
mais
RGPP la map est 2022 exercice 2022 ce ne
sont pas des revues de dépenses telles
que les pratiques plusieurs de nos
partenaires puisque ça a été demandé
comme l'Allemagne comme la Suède comme
le Canada une revue de dépenses et
l'exercice où met tout à plat de manière
systématique on fait des meilleures
démocratiques mais la donnée à
disposition
on regarde toutes les administrations
toutes les politiques publiques et ou à
partir de cela on fait le tri dans les
boîtiers publics entre ce qui marche qui
ne marche pas pour aboutir un système
qui avant tout est plus performant plus
efficace et plus juste et infinie qui
dégage les économies c'est pour ça que
je dis que ça n'est pas un exercice
budgétaires la finalité n'est pas
budgétaire le résultat est bien sûr mais
c'est l'inverse d'un exercice budgétaire
et j'ai l'outrecuidance de pensée que si
on ne le fait pas on ne réussira pas à
remplir nos objectifs budgétaires ou
alors on le fera de manière profondément
satisfaisante donc je ne suis pas pour
logique budgétaire a priori je suis pour
un constat apostériori d'économique qui
résulte une amélioration des politiques
publiques et c'est au fond la leçon que
je ne peux nous tirons de notre propre
exercice thématique non pas des chiffres
parce que c'est pas notre rôle je ne
suis pas un partisan du gouvernement des
juges et je ne suis pas un parti
renouvellement des expériences
gouvernement tu as lui de faire une show
budget et vous voulez proposer c'est à
vous de voter mesdames et messieurs les
députés non nous nous pouvons aider à la
décision c'est ça qui est notre rôle
pour ce qui est des OATi
bon nous avions demandé
que la PE revoit sa doctrine c'est vrai
que ça représente un montant élevé de la
dette moi je fais assez confiance à
l'Agence France Trésor pour la gestion
de la dette qui est plutôt de qualité
après son rapport de la première chambre
l'avait montré deux ans mais néanmoins
c'est-à-dire que c'est immuable il faut
donc tenir compte au fur et à mesure
disons que les oatir à mon sens je suis
pas la FT sera difficile de s'en passer
complètement parce que c'est pas une
répondre aux besoins de la caisse des
consignations notamment pour financer
l'opération sur l'épargne réglementaire
et donc ça rassure les investisseurs
donc c'est un équilibre à trouver mais
bon après c'est une question de choix
fin dont je ne suis pas capable et qui
ne sont pas dans dans ma compétence je
fais sur les aides économiques la même
réponse que j'ai faite sur les quotidien
local c'est à dire que nous y
reviendrons la semaine prochaine dans le
cadre de notre thématique puisqu'il y a
une des notes thématiques qui portent
là-dessus comme sur les dépenses
fiscales
sur enfin de questions sur les mesures
en matière de budget vert et autres il y
aura aussi une autre partie qui porte là
dessus mais nous sommes prêts aller plus
loin ce qui me permet de conclure pas
une réponse à votre remarque monsieur le
député holrogue je me fais toujours
violence et je continuerai tant que je
serai ici pour parler en tant que
responsable politique je l'ai été j'ai
commencé à marche ça ne change pas
complètement oublié et ça peut inspirer
parfois mes réflexions mais je ne le
suis plus je suis premier président de
la cour des comptes qui impose un
partialité indépendance et ça je m'y
tiens à 13 scrupuleusement je peux avoir
des idées comme citoyens et une
expérience comme responsable je suis
plus dans ce rôle là et je me garde de
tenir la main du gouvernement mais
peut-être et c'est à vous de savoir
pourquoi ce rôle était effectué à votre
sens de manière satisfaisante et je
crois très profondément que le Parlement
peut faire plus peut-être être une
question d'outillage plus capacité
d'indépendance capacité d'expertise
indépendante nous ne sommes pas dans un
système parlementaire de ce point de vue
j'ai été des vôtres j'ai même été des
vôtres membres de la commission des
finances
vos bureaux je veux dire au bureau sont
plus petits que ceux de nos homologues à
Washington et vos équipes aussi
même comme vous occupez des rôles
particuliers bon c'est comme ça que vous
allez voir un sénateur
Washington vous arrivez de 50 personnes
la commission des finances à des moyens
mais ils sont sans doute plus modestes
mais c'est bien de ça dont il s'agit
quand même c'est à dire de capacité à
challenger pas pour le défier pas pour
son défier l'administration et
l'expertise budgétaire et financière
dont dispose cette grande citadelle qui
est merci
cette fierté de dirigée pendant un
moment et je voudrais simplement vous
dire une chose c'est un message auquel
je tiens fondamentalement c'est que la
Cour des comptes vous ne le réalisez
peut-être pas suffisamment hello conseil
des finances publiques depuis la réforme
console de 2008 sont à équidistance
entre le Parlement et le gouvernement
et que je ne cesse de le dire la
capacité d'expertise dont nous disposons
elle est à votre service elle est à
votre service je pense que dans cette
affaire là nous sommes objectivement vos
alliés parce que nous n'avons pas nous
prononcer nous ne faisons pas de
politique en revanche notre capacité
d'expertise que nous dégageons nos
travaux c'est une aide éventuelle si
vous voulez vous en saisir pour vous
pour justement challenger le
gouvernement le Conseil des finances
publiques je sais pas ici comme
président de la président nouveau si je
me bats autant avec acharnement et
devant vous parfois pour qu'on en
renforce les moyens c'est pas pour
augmenter la taille du bureau en
l'occurrence c'est la bureaucratie c'est
parce que il faut avoir une capacité
d'indépendance suffisante pour mettre en
cause discuter les chiffres du
gouvernement c'est ce qu'on nos
partenaires nous ne l'avons pas et donc
je pense profondément que cette culture
là cette culture de partage et
d'équilibre des pouvoirs cette culture
de dialogue avec
exécutif c'est ce qui manque au pays oui
mais c'est une conclusion que je dirais
depuis longtemps j'ai même quand j'étais
misé finance je ne modifiais pas de cela
c'est pour ça que j'ai aussi créé le
conseil dans ces conditions je regrette
de pas lui avoir donné suffisamment de
moyens mon administration ne le
souhaitait pas vraiment à l'époque mais
c'est quelque chose de fondamental c'est
vous travaillez monsieur le député sur
la réforme des règles c'est rencontré à
cet égard
d'ailleurs vous écris un courrier suite
à notre rencontre pour vous dire assez
précisément ce que je crois je pense que
si nous renforçons les autorités
indépendantes l'expertise indépendante
si nous renforçons notre capacité
collective au niveau parlementaire au
niveau de la cour au niveau du Haut
Conseil à d'autres niveaux encore pour
produire des chiffres des faits et bien
le débat public se comportera mieux
c'est aussi une condition pour réussir
la revue des portes publiques car c'est
ça mon dernier message moi je crois très
profondément cet exercice de rue des
pensées je vous le redis nous ne l'avons
jamais fait notre pays je dis bien
jamais je pense que si nous le faisons
ce serait une manière beaucoup plus
intelligente que je ne sais quelle
démarche strictement budgétaire pour
parvenir à de meilleurs résultats des
finances publiques et surtout en termes
de qualité de la dépense publique de
qualité du service public de
satisfaction de l'usager citoyen pour
lequel nous travaillons les uns et les
autres
merci monsieur le Président je ne peux
que appuyer l'anesthé de moyen pour élan
n'hésitez toujours d'indépendance de la
commission des finances par rapport à
l'exécutif de façon à pouvoir contrôler
des choses et je voulais également dire
que c'est vrai ce que vous dites sur les
moyens on a une chance quand même c'est
qu'on a des administrateurs de qualité
absolument remarquables auxquelles je
tiens à rendre hommage
à la fin de cette session ordinaire
voilà merci beaucoup à bientôt